oh my god
some things are just no match for the
power of a hurricane like ida the roof
of this hospital ripped off
no surprise then that louisiana woke up
to scenes like this widespread damage
and a search operation for those who'd
stayed behind those who can be helped
and those for whom it's too late
what is most remarkable about ida is
just how long it remained a major
hurricane over land battering places
like new orleans for hours
they're used to hurricanes in the city
they call the big easy exactly 16 years
ago katrina was devastating this place
this time the levees appear to have held
firm
i'm nowhere near like katrina
but it could have been if it would have
hit here i think it hit home instead
home of louisiana
that's where the
majority of
the eyewall
went to home
ida had made landfall on the barrier
islands to the south the authorities
believe they hoped that everyone had
left before this arrived
this storm surge was the thing that
worried emergency services the most they
say parts of this coast could be
uninhabitable for weeks
robust search and rescue is happening
right now
and i fully expected that death count
will go up considerably throughout the
day we're going to get through this it's
going to take some time and the cleanup
is going to is going to take a number of
weeks and months
thousands of people will face a long and
arduous recovery from this
it will be days before they know exactly
what ida's left behind
more immediately the whole of new
orleans remains without power after what
they called catastrophic damage to the
electricity grid the concern
is that many will have lost a lot more
the destruction on earth viewed from
space and ida still isn't done yet
you